>> IRAN LIED ABOUT NEVER HAVING
A NUCLEAR WEAPON'S PROGRAM.
AND IT IS BASED ON LIES.
IT IS BASED  ON IRANIAN LIES AND
DECEPTION.
AND IN A FEW DAYS PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL DECIDE ON WHAT TO DO
WITH THE NUCLEAR DEAL.
I AM SURE HE WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE UNITED STATES, THE
RIGHT THING FOR THE PEACE OF THE
WORLD.
>> Bret: THAT IS NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE SITUATION.
I HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT IS
HAPPENING.
THEY ARE NOT SETTING BACK IDLY.
THEY SET OFF MISSILES FOR
TELEVISION PURPOSES.
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Bret: THE ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER WITH A LAID OUT DETAIL
THAT THEY GOT FROM IRAN.
THE IRANIANS PUSHING BACK ON
TWITTER, BREAKING, THE BOY WHO
CAN'T STOP TRYING WOLF
UNDETERRED BY THE CARTOON.
YOU CAN ONLY FOOL SOME OF THE
PEOPLE SOME OF THE TIME.
THE SERIOUSNESS IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
DECIDES WHETHER TO PULL OUT OF
THE NUCLEAR DEAL.
AND THAT IS TOWN HALL.COM.
AND HOSTED A NEW SHOW ON FOX
RADIO.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT.
AND WE HAVE MOLLY HEMMINGWAY
EDITOR OF THE FEDERALIST.
YOU HEARD THE AMBASSADOR SAYING
HOW SERIOUS IT IS WITH THE REAMS
OF INFORMATION THAT THE ISRAELIS
GOT ABOUT THE NUCLEAR WEAPON.
>> WHAT NETANYAHU DID IN SIMPLE
AND CLEAR EXPOSITION WITH BIG
LETTER AND GRAPHICS IS GIVE THE
REASONS WHY THE IRANIAN DEAL WAS
BAD.
HE DIDN'T EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THE U.S. GOTS OUT.
BUT HE COROB GREATED THE
PRESIDENT'S INSTINCTS.
>> Bret: A LOVE OF PEOPLE WERE
DOING IT FOR AN AUDIENCE OF ONE.
>> I NOTICED AND I THINK THAT IS
DISAGREEING.
THE REAL CONFLICT IS WITH THE
AND FIND A WAY TO KEEP IT GOING.
LEARNING THAT WILL AND FAILING
TO BE HONEST MEANS THAT THE DEAL
IS NOT GO PRVMENT AND THERE IS
NOTHING THAT YOU CAN DO BOWS U.
AND THERE IS A FALSEHOOD IN THE
FOUNDATION OF THE DEAL.
>> RIGHT THE STRUCTURE SAID
ESSENTIALLY THAT THE HONEST
STATEMENTS IN THE BEGINNING.
AND IT FIRST COMMRI CAPTAINS
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AS A PREREQUESTIONSIT FOOTBALL
AND THE REQUIREMENT MUCH IRAN
WAS TO TEST FULLY AND FULL.
THE IRANIANS LIED THROUGH THEIR
TEETH SAYING THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A NUCLEAR WEAPON 'PROGRAM AND WE
SEE TODAY STRONG EVIDENCE THAT
WAS LAID OUT CLEARLY FROM THE
ISRAELIS THAT THAT WAS
UNIVERSITY NOT TRUE.
THE IRANIANS ARE.
AND SINCE 2003 HCHL.
AND IT IS STILL IN CONTROL OF
THE COLETTER.
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS A POWERFUL